and tonight A South mecklinburg science
teacher is out of jail after accusations
she engaged in a sexual act with an
18-year-old student Gabriela Newfield
made her first court appearance in
meinberg County courts today after
bonding out of jail this morning police
say they arrested the educator for an
alleged sexual act yesterday officers
say she met up with a student outside of
school at Park Road or Park Road Park
yeah one aspect of this case though that
is causing a lot of confusion tonight
the age of this student yeah some
viewers are asking over social media how
the teacher is facing a felony charge if
the student is technically a legal adult
at 18 years of age we now go to our
verify reporter Megan Bragg CU power
dynamics yeah she's a teacher she's a
teacher yeah so he continues and he yeah
it is what it is well we posted this
story on our Facebook page and had
several viewers asking since the student
was 18 years old which makes him legally
an adult how can the teacher be charged
with a crime so let's get the facts here
we went to to North Carolina law South
Carolina law and Aaron Lee he's a
criminal defense attorney okay so in
North Carolina it is illegal for a
teacher or any school Personnel to have
a sexual relationship with any student
if that teacher is four years older than
the victim which in this case she was it
makes no difference whether the sexual
activity was consensual or not and
according to the law in cases like this
teachers administrators or coaches can
be charged with a
felony the student is in a position of
vulnerability to the teacher a position
of trust for them so you don't want to
have a teacher who can manipulate a
person's consent just like a doctor
attorney therapist when you have that
relationship of trust and role Mobility
it uh poses a bigger risk to the
victim okay so the only exception is if
the student and teacher are married to
each other now get him out of here bro
get him the [__] up out of here
bro then see I was like following this
[__] and then they said married like so
what can a doctor just I know or like
psychologist start marrying their
mentally ill patient like yo [__] okay
whatever at 18 [__] out of here all
right the sex part is like but you get
married like a
whole in South Carolina it is a little
different if if a teacher or School
Personnel engages in sexual activity
with a student who is a minor they can
be charged with a felony however if a
student is 18 or older and if the sex is
consensual then the crime is bumped down
to a misdemeanor misdemeanor
Mis now we get into the whole gray here
it's so funny like you can be North
Carolina and you going to jail for a
long time you go to South Caroline it's
like here's $50 beg him again if you
want to take a chance just
move move you should have taken that man
across state lines he was pet where you
want to meet over in North Carolina why
you want to meet in North
Carolina I don't know here's the thing
this relationship and why they made it
illegal makes sense to me because I can
see plenty of scenarios where somebody
who's in a position of trust like this
can take advantage of that right so for
me it' be context dependent do I think
this is inherently wrong that an
18-year-old slept with a 26-year-old not
necessarily the fact that it was a
teacher does it make it very red flaggy
absolutely
absolutely does because think about it
in this context imagine if there's some
quit Pro thing you want good grades and
trust me there's there's teachers in my
city who banging the University students
for grades there's a lot of college
professors T who banging for grades for
recommendations for you know
dissertations for like their masters
yeah there's a lot of that stuff and so
I think that's completely unethical and
it should be met with a firing at the
very least and potential J jail time to
make it a deter in society because you
don't want to crumble like the very
institutions that kind of foster the
Next Generation with corruption like
that in my opinion so with this
situation if there was no quid proquo if
they have no evidence of that if this is
just two adults and one happens to be
the teacher I'm not too keen on the idea
of sending them immediately to jail me
personally uh but I'm perfectly fine
with firing them I'm perfectly fine with
removing their teachers
license but jail seems a bit excessive
to me especially if they're both
consenting adults what do you think yeah
the marriage part [__] me up though
true cuz I don't see how that's possible
without the other that's really like a
thinking that oh yeah well you to have
they could have uh a marriage without
sex and I'm like okay so so sleeping
with a student is coercion you know for
grades but you don't think that same
person could coarse a teenager to marry
them
and then you want to know the logic what
it
is this is that religious Bible 100%
100% 100% they'll say the law the law
then they'll bring the religious aspect
to and they try to justify it's like
that doesn't make any sense to me that
standard in fact I would argue one is
far more harmful marrying your student
when they're that Fresh Off is far worse
than just sleeping with them in my
opinion
100% um I'm also pretty B on this
because when I was like 19 I was like
with somebody who's 27 so for me it
wasn't a big deal but it was my teach or
anything like that you know what I'm
saying it was great so that just a good
old lady 27's old lady when you're 19 no
when you're 19 27 is uh you're like okay
it's a glimpse of the future yeah and
it's nice and it's experienced and it
knows what it doing and it doesn't use
its
teeth yeah buddy you had a gummy worm no
she wasn't a gummy worm okay she knew
that she knew how to yeah she just knew
how to do her thing yeah good time I all
say good if home girl look cute like if
she was my biology teacher I like hey I
need a lesson anatomy in the back seat
what can we get this popping so I'm not
even mad but Hey listen I could be also
biased because it's a dude and an older
woman maybe that's playing a part of it
maybe it's my own personal biases it's
kind of look like Alicia G
yeah
I was going to get to the day part but
you beat me to it you went right to it
sorry you just went to it just like her
she went right to it anyways no one no
one no one can find out you better keep
your mouth
shut get in the
back that's the one she did with Usher
that was like the song of the year yeah
yeah yeah that was the song of the year
when it came out and that's in my
opinion ATA ke biggest song no I think
no one may be more of a pop song fall in
was huge falling was more cultural it
was not asig it was bigger it was no no
it was bigger for black people not
bigger internationally no one is
actually I hate the song no one but
that's her biggest song I suspect let me
see I think Ma Bo is probably the
biggest song but we'll find out no one
is the biggest commerci I thought you
were talking about my boo yeah yeah
you're right my Bo's bigger than fall
okay let's find out at least he keeps
falling but no one is yeah no one was
everywhere I hatte it was in the what in
a grocery store you know it's done yeah
if I start Michael bé no one topped hot
Billboards 100 for five weeks straight
the hot R&B charts for 10 weeks straight
and was the most played song on American
radio stations in 2007 yeah that's
definitely number one where's my boo
it's not even on this list is it a Usher
song it's not it's a Usher song uh My
Boo Usher the song stayed on top of the
Billboard's Hot 100 for 6 weeks even
more than no one okay and what about uh
making it the third most successful
single after yeah and burn which are
huge it is an Usher song though so it
doesn't count so I will concede to you
cuz it's an Usher song but I think it's
bigger so what about the the first one
we don't know about fing uh 2001 it
topped the Billboard 100 for the first 6
weeks so it's up there with my boo yeah
but my boo was five no my boo is six my
okay boo was five was no one you know
what though I I'll give it to you you
want I give it to you because it's song
but fair it's it's I prefer fall falling
was was when I put Alicia on the map for
myself
well that was her first that album was
amazing that was her first song that was
her last good album that was her first
song her first and last one after that
it was a bunch of no I hate that song
Personally no one no yeah CU she went
from that sful stuff to that pop sound
with like cuz what she was before that
when she was on the keys and she was
making beautiful ballads that was very
different than
the that ugly ass organ sounding y she
she she she doubled down with the don't
break everything
[__] I saw that she doubled down with
the New York thing with Kanye she did
one with Kanye yeah yeah that was I
think her transition was kind of whack
in my opinion but anyways uh all this to
say at leici keys in the back seat at 18
I would have left so wow would wouldn't
you guys at home watching if Felicia
Keys was your [__]
biology professor at University and she
was trying to like yo dig me down in the
back seat you be like I'm falling for
you right now let's go you wouldn't do
that at the time I like my confidence
was not there so I would I would I'm
like it's a trap it's a trap you
wouldn't a TR I would believe oh okay
it's a [__] trap you want to bring
cameras and reject me in front of
everybody yeah [__] you [__] who's in
on the joke who's in on the joke [__]
but I have to confess one thing I am
biased on this because it is a woman but
what I feel differently if a dude was
trying to get with a 18-year-old like I
think he should be fired the same way
the woman should be fired I think should
go to jail no respect of sex I think I
feel very similar but I won't lie to you
I'd probably find it weird if it was a
dude doing for sure but that's my
subconscious bias so I can admit to that
anything else no you don't you have you
have that bias too
yeah it's cuz you're a blue pill and you
don't like
me sure are you going to deny the
claim I plead the
fifth y'all heard it here first what did
I plead the fifth
no your blue be accepted you said it and
it's
true all right see y'all next week also
we have a Discord [__] hey we have a
Reddit get up there comment people
always kind of make I'm watching I'm
reading I go on the subreddit I be
taking cop topics from there sometimes